this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep my god am i in love with eight
sleep
good sleep is the ultimate game changer
more than 30 percent of americans
struggle with sleep
and i'm a member of that sad group
temperature is one of the main causes of
poor sleep and heat has always been my
nemesis
i've suffered for decades tossing and
turning throwing blankets off putting
them back
on and repeating ad nauseam but now i am
falling asleep
in record time faster than ever why
because i'm using a simple device called
the pod pro cover by eight sleep it's
the easiest
and fastest way to sleep at the perfect
temperature it pairs dynamic cooling and
heating with biometric tracking to offer
the most advanced
but most user-friendly solution on the
market
i polled all of you guys on social media
about the best tools
for sleep enhancing sleep and
aidsleep was by far and away the crowd
favorite i mean people were just
raving fans of this so i used it and
here we are
add the pod pro cover to your current
mattress and start sleeping
as cool as 55 degrees fahrenheit or as
hot as 110 degrees fahrenheit
it also splits your bed in half so your
partner can choose a totally different
temperature
my girlfriend runs hot all the time she
doesn't need
cooling she loves the heat and we can
have our own bespoke temperatures on
either side which is exactly what we're
doing
now for me and for many people the
result eight sleep users
fall asleep up to 32 percent faster
reduce sleep interruptions by up to 40
percent and get more restful sleep
overall
i can personally attest to this because
i track it in all sorts of ways it's the
total solution
for enhanced recovery so you can take on
the next day feeling
refreshed and now my dear listeners
that's you guys you can get two hundred
and fifty dollars off of the pod pro
cover that's a lot
simply go to eight sleep dot com slash
tim
or use code tim that's eight all spelled
out
e-i-g-h-t sleep dot com
slash tim or use coupon code tim
t-i-m-eight sleep dot com slash tim
for 200 off your pod pro cover
this episode is brought to you by magic
spoon magic spoon is a brand new cereal
that i eat just about every day that is
low carb high protein and zero
sugar i just ate a huge bowl of their
cocoa flavor
about an hour ago after a short workout
magic spoon cereal
has received a lot of attention since
launching last year
time magazine included it in their list
of best inventions of 2019
and forbes called it the future of
cereal it tastes just like your favorite
sugary cereal from childhood remember
that
but it's actually good for you each
serving has 11 grams of protein
3 grams of net carbs 0 grams of sugar
and only 110 calories it's also gluten
free grain free keto friendly soy
free and gmo free all the things it's
delicious
and i don't see that lightly because
most of this healthy
version of x stuff is not delicious but
these guys really nail it magic spoon
has nailed it it comes in your favorite
traditional
cereal flavors like cocoa frosted and
blueberry you can try them all by
grabbing a variety pack
at magicspoon.comtim or you can just
grab a box
or a bunch of boxes i'm going to order
some more today of the cocoa which is my
personal favorite but there is a new
contender for favorite flavor because
they just
launched two limited edition flavors
honey nut and peanut butter which are
delicious i am a sucker for peanut
butter
and it is outstanding so i think cocoa
and peanut butter are my two new
favorite flavors and fun fact
my friends are also obsessed with magic
spoon one of the podcasts
most popular guest dr peter tia
routinely crushes six to seven servings
at a time that's a lot with no glycemic
response he's looked at this with a
glucometer
he likes it so much he invested other
friends two
very fine gentlemen and also past
podcast guests kevin rose and ryan
holiday
also invested so go to magicspoon.com
tim to grab some delicious cereal and
try it for yourself today
use promo code tim that's tim at
checkout to save five dollars off of
your order
and magic spoon is so confident in their
product i have boxes and boxes and boxes
it's backed with a 100 percent happiness
guarantee so
if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money no
questions asked get your next delicious
bowl of guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com
tim and use the code tim to get five
dollars off
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i answer your personal questions
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoscopy
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show where it
is my job each and every episode to
interview world-class performers from
all different disciplines
all different walks of life to tease out
the frameworks
lessons learned and so on that you can
apply to your own lives my guest today
is jacqueline novogratz you can find her
on twitter at
j novogratz n-o-v-o-g-r-a-t-z
she is the founder and ceo of acumen in
2001
jacqueline started acumen with the idea
of investing philanthropic patient
capital we will talk about what that
means
in entrepreneurs seeking to solve the
toughest issues of poverty
as a pioneer of impact investing acumen
and its investments have brought
critical services like healthcare
education and clean energy to hundreds
of millions
of low-income people that's a big number
folks let that sink in
after supporting hundreds of
entrepreneurs jacqueline and her team
recognize
character as the crucial ingredient for
success in 2020 they launched acumen
academy to instruct others in
global social change under jaclyn's
leadership acumen has also launched
several for-profit impact funds designed
to invest at the intersection of poverty
and climate change
and has spun off 60 decibels founded on
the principle
that serving all stakeholders is as
important as enriching
shareholders jacqueline is the new york
times bestselling author of the blue
sweater
i'm sure we will talk about what that
means and refers to
and manifesto for a moral revolution
practices to build a better world
she's been named one of the top 100
global thinkers by foreign policy
one of the 25 smartest people of decade
by the daily beast and one of the
world's 100 greatest living business
minds by forbes which also honored her
with the forbes 400
lifetime achievement award for social
entrepreneurship
all that means yes i'm nervous to
interview this person
linkedin you can find her jaclyn hyphen
novogratz twitter
j novogratz instagram also at j
novogratz and of course you can find
acumen
at acumen.org jacqueline welcome to the
show
it's great to be here with you tim thank
you and uh
i'm going to just go with the layup
i'm not going to say lazy question it's
really more of a
setting of the backdrop for people who
don't know you could you please describe
your childhood your parents just give us
a little bit of color there
so we know from where you have come i
was
raised in a four bedroom house with
seven siblings
the seven of us amazing parents dad was
in the military
my mother was a force to be reckoned
with i would say it was a
noisy chaotic loving house full of
cowboys who are also expected to somehow
be good
number of your siblings have also gone
on
to do great things very much on a
national and global scale
to what do you attribute that is it just
inheriting good software
is it environmental are there any
particular inputs or
habits that your parents have anything
that comes to mind i'm sure you've been
asked this before but
what was in the drinking water so to
speak i think it was a funny combination
of one constraint that when you have
so many kids on a military income
you got to get entrepreneurial young
fast
and that was probably a very important
piece number two
my mother is one of the great myth
makers of all times myth makers
myth makers i remember when we were
little bob mike and i
all we really wanted was levi's jeans
there weren't a lot of things to
differentiate us so my mother made a
deal with us and said
look i'll buy you the dungarees which is
what they used to call
jeans from the post exchange unless
you can earn the difference for those
levi's but i have to tell you i'm really
disappointed in you guys
why would you need brands you're
novogratzes
and we laugh now we're like what the
hell was in novogratz
but she had the sense that this was who
we were
so two kind of a driven myth-making
mother
and three this big extended immigrant
catholic family
and so this idea that to whom much is
given much is expected was also
reinforced
and so i guess in a funny way
tim we grew up in a tribe but also
allowed to be wild individualists who
had to be entrepreneurial and here we
are
so you're known for impact investing
social impact and all the things that we
or i should say i mentioned in the bio
that i just read
but that's not where things began from
square one you weren't just hatched out
of the egg as this
imminent world change or maybe you were
on some level i mean uh your brother
mike novogratz who's been on the podcast
talked about how
you have had this very clear north star
for seemingly uh
much of your life but that wasn't the
first step in other words you didn't
just
graduate from high school and start
acumen could you
just walk us through your first
professional decisions where did you go
after school
and why did you go there i think i did
always want to change the world from the
time i was six and i guess that was part
of the
both the positive and the pressure
and so there was always that idea that i
had but
to go through college certainly as the
first we had to pay for school
and so i worked two three jobs the
entire time i was at the university of
virginia
what were your jobs what types of jobs
well mostly i was a bartender
and in the summer i worked 100 hours a
week as a bartender which was actually
quite something
when i graduated i told my parents that
i'd really never had a
proper vacation and that i was going to
take a year to
just explore the world never really gone
outside the united states or anything
like that and my parents being very wise
said
we think that's fine but at least go
through the interview process
and so i agreed quite reluctantly
and i threw my resume without thinking
into the boxes for foreign affairs econ
majors which were my majors
and chase manhattan bank called and said
we'll take you in as an interview and so
i go into the interview and there's this
cute guy sitting across the table from
me
and he says tell me jacqueline why do
you want to be a banker
which was of course the only question i
wasn't ready for and so
i was like actually my mom and dad are
making me do this
i don't want to be a banker and he said
that's what you said
yeah yeah i mean i
don't know it's probably the only answer
he wasn't prepared for
but what something in him was prepared
because he was like well
if you got this job you would be in 40
countries the next three years and you
would be understanding the economic and
political
situation in each of those countries and
of course as this kid that
always dreamed of knowing the world
loving the world
i was like oh god so i said could we
start this interview over and he let me
literally leave the room i knocked on
the door i introduced myself i sat down
he was like
tell me jacqueline why do you want to be
a banker and i said ever since i was six
years old all i ever wanted to do was be
a banker
of course there were interviews after
that to make sure i had a brain but i
got the job
and sure enough for the next three years
i was in
40 countries at a really extraordinary
time when the financial systems were
also in peril in the early 1980s
that was my first job now how did you
end up
traveling the world i suppose thinking
back to my own undergrad experience and
the recruiting on campus by
investment banks and so on although this
may not have been in the investment
banking
category but when i think the promises
of various recruiters
i associate the you're gonna travel the
world meet fascinating people
learn various a b and c about x y and z
industries i associate that with the
management consulting pitch
so what was the job that you ended up
getting that allowed you to
travel like that in banking it was an
extraordinary job it was called credit
audit
where the bank hired primarily liberal
arts
majors i think young people who
were critical thinkers who asked the
dumb questions
and they literally would send us around
the world
a month at a time i think i was in new
york three weeks one year
and you would just get this note on your
desk that you had to be in kuala lumpur
three days from then in a package of
travelers checks which is the way that
we would get money
and a reservation in hotel and we would
go and so
it's one way the world has really
changed because i remember talking to my
boss because i had a reputation for
unwittingly getting people fired by
asking the really dumb questions
and then uncovering i can't let that go
without asking for an example
how does that happen what would a
hypothetical or real
type of question or or actual question
be that might get someone fired
the biggest one for me was in
switzerland when i was
um pretty much a solo act to look at
this whole suite of swiss banks
which everybody just assumed were
safe because of swiss banking
and tim i kept looking at the numbers
and the spreadsheets for this
one bank and nothing added up to me
and so i went to the head of the
division the office
and i was incredibly nervous because i
wasn't that confident that i
was that great at all these spreadsheets
and i pointed out
what i saw as real flaws and real
vulnerabilities and
he essentially told me i was too young
too naive didn't i understand
swiss banking and that the bank was
completely protected
and i scratched my head i went back the
numbers still didn't work
i called my boss he yelled at me and i
just knew
that i might be wrong i might be
all those things he said but i could
only tell my truth
and i literally had to hold on to the
chair
because i was so afraid and i turned it
in i gave it
in those days a seven which put it on a
big warning list which meant it went all
the way to the top of the bank and it
turned out that
i was right the bank failed and i
learned really young tim
that i went from being seen as
kind of scared and not that serious
overnight to them being seen as this
whiz kid
i was the same person nothing had
changed
and how ephemeral the way the world
sees you became to me because i know
that i was exactly the same woman the
morning after that i was the morning
before
so i guess learning really young
sometimes just speak that truth even
through trembling lips yeah wow what a
story
i mean it's it's something that so few
people especially new hires
would actually dare to do
it just strikes me as unusual
that you would have the conviction to
potentially and i don't know the
politicking or the power dynamics inside
of that bank obviously but to piss off
your boss by giving it a seven which
then
flies straight up the flagpole after
getting reprimanded
that's quite a move it sounds like that
wasn't a
first though that you sort of cultivated
this speaking of truth
coming up to that point is that accurate
yeah i think it probably was and in fact
god you're already making me get
emotional but i think i saw myself as
less courageous a voice than other
people experienced me as a
great gift of my latest book where i
talked about the need to learn how to
use voice
was that one of my colleagues at the
time
who i haven't you know hadn't seen in
more than 30 years
it was like you were always the one that
was standing
and i think i always stood for the
underdog but i
also just couldn't tell a lie and
they hired me for a particular purpose
and i felt like that was my
duty that was just my job as a kid i was
the one that
would fight for the underdog in fact i
got thrown out of trigonometry
for standing up for what was right what
were you standing up for was it the
answer to something or was it a person
no
the teacher he was a great pop quiz guy
and he had promised us that
we wouldn't get a pop quiz that week and
one of my friends
had been sick and she was very very
insecure when it came to trigonometry
i said you don't have to worry about it
because this teacher
told us that we weren't going to have a
pop quiz and promised us
and then of course he gave us the pop
quiz and i just felt such
a need to protect my friend that i stood
up i made a big
deal about it and that was the end that
was my last day of trigonometry
for that year and the worst of it is i
had to do home economics
for the last six weeks of the year
just imagining how happy you were about
that but i think it's worth
really underscoring that you develop
this and reinforce this truth speaking
you take some lumps of course you're
going to take lumps
along the way but ultimately not to
attribute all of your successes to that
but
i think it's no small thing one of the
aspects of your story that has stuck out
to me as i'm doing homework
is the power of asking
i wouldn't say dumb questions asking the
questions right
asking questions and speaking truth and
it's just how
you talk about patient capital we might
talk later about how it's differentiated
from just
long-term capital and long-term
investing and how you differentiate the
two but
if you're making a long-term sort of
patient investment in yourself like over
the short term you might get
reprimanded for truth and asking
questions
or seemingly naive questions but they
seem to be really good long-term
bets and i suppose there's not a
question so much in that but
does that resonate with you as being
true
how does that land for you when i say
that am i missing anything i've actually
never thought about it
for myself personally but it deeply
resonates that
i am not comfortable and it's hard
sometimes both for people who work with
me and
for the people who take our courses
online at laying out a roadmap because
the world is too complex for a
step-by-step
guide to how to solve poverty but what
we
do have is a compass a moral compass and
that
speaking of truth and standing for truth
not only builds a sense of courage but
it deepens
i think once and certainly my own
understanding of where lines are
so yeah so thank you for that yeah also
i know this i'm getting on a caffeinated
soapbox here for a second but we're
going to cover a lot of ground so we
have space for my caffeinated soap box
and that is to say
these things don't manifest out of the
ether
when you need them most necessarily
right you were
practicing and conditioning yourself to
tell the truth
and you had a choice to stuff or to
speak
in that moment you made the decision to
speak
rated to seven and that gave you the
positive reinforcement i have to imagine
and more confidence to continue doing
the same but it's a skill
and it seems like a practice that you
need to reinforce let's come back to
this banking
in your retake ever since the age of six
i've always known i wanted to be a
banker
clearly you're no longer a banker so
what happened
what happened you're doing these audits
and where where does the next chapter
enter the picture
so it started again
having always dreamed of traveling
around the world and knowing and loving
the world in fact
now i'm in brazil and chile and ecuador
and and truly colombia falling in love
with the vibrancy the color
these stories that as a young american
kid we didn't ever get
about the developing world and it struck
me
in this era again tim when the banks
were falling apart
they had been making all these bets
based on relationship
and long-term debt and suddenly the
the markets were in crisis and they
wanted to call all their loans and
and they lost hundreds and hundreds of
millions of dollars billions of dollars
at that time
so i would sit inside the bank looking
at loans that should never have been
made
often money that was actually never even
put into what it said it would be put
into
meanwhile on the weekends i would just
be drawn to the favelas and into the
slums and
into these parts of the cities that were
so full of life and vibrancy and
work and diligent people and i would
talk to people about their businesses
and realize that this was a group of
people that could not even
walk in through the doors of the bank
they had no confidence
with the banking system and so i again
asking dumb questions which may be a
theme of my life went to my boss with
all good faith
and said that maybe we would do better
for the country do better for the people
and actually get our money back do
better for the bank if we actually
made smaller loans to local people doing
what they were
doing and he literally gave me a book
called the innocent anthropologist
and it became very clear to me that the
bank
wasn't ready to pivot in that way
and so i had to go outside which is
where i've stayed
trying to disrupt systems from the
outside not the inside which i think i'm
better at
so the innocent anthropologist i assume
was a very
formalized way of giving you a book that
basically says listen kid
that's adorable but also very naive i
mean is that the thrust
of that gift yeah i mean he gave me two
gifts
actually that was the first gift and
then when we were
talking a little bit later and he was
trying to convince me to stay at the
bank he's like look
you're one of our top producers and
performers but
culturally you don't really fit you
dress like linda rod's net and you laugh
too much
which now i think may have been code for
you're not actually
acting enough like you know an elite one
of us
and i realized in that moment that not
only did i want to see how we could
actually use the tools of banking to
solve poverty
but that if i stayed that he was
essentially asking me to be a completely
different person
and that helped make the decision what
was your next move
you know some people get to checkmate in
one move but
it's often an evolution where did you go
from there well the next move was
telling my parents
that i had to have made the decision oh
yeah
yeah tell us tell us about that giving
up on
you know this middle-class immigrant
family
saw as the job of lifetime and to make
it worse the ceo
of chase tony tristiano who just such an
amazing man
was giving me an opportunity then i
think he liked that i was the scrappy
bartender girl
and not the more refined version that my
immediate boss wanted he really gave me
an opportunity
that could have changed would have
changed the direct trajectory of my life
my dad thought i was giving up that
opportunity my mother thought i would
never marry
both had truth in what they were saying
and so i think that was incredibly hard
because i we were all raised to
quote unquote do the right thing i was
looking for an opportunity to get to
brazil
but i found one that would bring me to
west africa which was absolutely not
on my playbook but i realized that this
was a chance
to pursue a different kind of dream that
was looking at taking the tools of
banking and reaching low income people
i read about muhammad yunus in the
grammy bank and and other heroes of mine
and i wanted to try it myself and so i
went
and as you said it was sort of a next
move i i met with
absolute crushing failure made all the
worse because i turned down this really
big job offer
so we're we're going to definitely roll
up our sleeves and get into the crushing
failure but before we do maybe we'll
we'll get into another failure i have no
idea because i don't know the details of
this but
how did the conversation with your
parents go did you deliver it in a way
that they were able to hear if so what
was that way
did you try it and they were just like
terrible idea
time will tell watch us you know this is
the end that was the end of the
conversation i mean how did it turn out
and how did you approach it or maybe the
other way around
well i just told them what i was going
to do so you didn't say i'm thinking of
x you're just like
this is what i'm doing i'm giving you
guys a heads up
heads up this is really you know it's
not such a request it's a
this is what i'm going to do next and my
mother is like you are out of your mind
she could be very forceful then and what
she will say now
is that she kind of understood by then
that i had a very strong
will when i decided something i don't
think i quite understood until much
later how
afraid they were this is pre-internet
pre-cell phone
pre real understanding of
what this big continent was about the
only images
they had of africa was a as almost as a
single country rather than 54
all looking like ethiopia during the
famine of 1983.
probably the worst thing that she said
to me was you know i could understand if
you were a nun
and i was like what are you doing
i think there was a lot of fear i think
there was a lot of fear
what's been so thrilling is to watch
them along the journey not only feel
deeply proud but get more and more
excited and that happened fairly quickly
as long as we had a few rules
if i went to a war zone i didn't tell
them until after i got back
because communication was too hard it
was not fair to them
i think those are things that parents
don't have to deal with today because
they can
be in more constant contact so before we
get to the crushing defeat
which i definitely want to spend a
little time on how did you find the next
opportunity because i think many people
listening
will have they will have some experience
maybe it's a current experience of doing
something that generates income but that
is not
deeply rewarding to them on some level
and they want to have a greater impact
they don't know what to do
i'm not asking so much for prescriptive
advice yet we might get to that
but how did you at that time especially
this is pre-internet
how did you find this next lily pad to
jump to
and then please tell us about your
crushing defeat again we had
far less tools then and so
i had read one tiny article about
grammy bank which was still very obscure
i sent a letter to muhammad yunus
that probably never reached bangladesh
and then i
heard from a young woman who also was at
chase
that her aunt had started an
organization called women's world
banking
and that there might be an opportunity
so i just went there
and offered myself to go to brazil and
as i said
she said we don't have any opportunity
there we do though in
west africa and i just took it it was
super risky it didn't come with health
insurance it just
was an opportunity i knew that if i were
waiting for the perfect i wouldn't have
done it
i also knew i might lose my nerve and it
was the only thing that was on
offer to really test out my theory that
the tools of business and banking could
actually serve
people who had been fully left out and i
don't think it was until i was actually
on the plane listening to joni
mitchell's
blue album over and over and weeping
that it really hit me
that i was i was on my own
why were you weeping was it fear was it
something else
i think it was loss everything i'd left
behind
no understanding of where i was going
fear
a lot of loss in transition and then the
minute i landed
both excitement for being there and yet
almost immediate confrontation
with the first big true
failure of my life which was that i had
been
told that i had this opportunity to be
an ambassador to you know african women
and i was going to help build all these
microfinance organizations across the
region
and i would say the arrogance underneath
was that i was going to save the world
at least this part of it and what
the confrontation helped me understand
pretty quickly was that most people
don't want to be saved
and certainly not by a 25 year old white
american girl
who's french was not very good and
and who had very little understanding
whatsoever of the local culture
and so i hung in there for a number of
months
it was very hairy hairy in what way
everything from just a kind of a daily
rejection where i would go to
my little office in the african
development bank and the door would be
locked
or i was supposed to do this big
conference and i would
ask people for help and they'd be like
that's not my job
okay i didn't really know where to go
and then this one nigerian extraordinary
woman befriended me
and she was like you know they really
want you out the powers that be
and so don't eat anything in front of
the women who didn't want me in the
country and i said what do you mean
don't eat anything she's like well
they're
they're going to poison you and they're
also talking about voodoo holy [ __ ]
jesus so um
and you know i don't believe in voodoo
but i will tell you
when you are stripped down to nothing
and you're afraid to eat anything in
front of people and you're being locked
out of your office and
you don't really have much of a safety
at nor do you know a
single person except for this incredible
nigerian woman who's befriended you
i would lie in bed and be like is
anybody here coming to get
me and um and then i got
unbelievably sick with food poisoning
like deathly sick did you think it was
poisoning or did you think it was food
poisoning i mean after hearing that
story my god i mean i would imagine
i couldn't go there i couldn't go there
she thought
it might be poisoning but i didn't
remember eating anything in front of
anybody
and i was a little thing to start off
with and so
after about eight days of just lying on
the bathroom floor
i decided it was enough and told the
women trying to be respectful but also
clear
that i i got what they were saying i
really heard
that they had not asked for anybody like
me and that we don't
we shouldn't be just parachuting in to
go and
build things without doing it in real
partnership
and that that was a mistake on every
level including mine
and nobody should be treated the way
that they treated
me and that both were true that said i
left everything that i owned
in the boxes that i had in in the
abhijan hilton
goodness knows whatever happened to them
and i moved to east africa
where i kind of started again hopefully
with a lot more humility
and maybe a different kind of courage
was it
with the same organization
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
linkedin jobs small business owners have
always shown an incredible ability to
adapt and innovate
this past year has certainly highlighted
many examples
now another way you can adapt and
innovate in 2021
is by finding the right people to help
you grow your business
linkedin jobs makes it possible for you
to do exactly that
get started by posting your job for free
to reach linkedin's network of more than
740
million professionals fill out targeted
screening questions to get your role in
front of the most qualified candidates
with the experience skills and
motivation you're looking for
then with simple filtering and
management tools you can easily review
rate and home in on your top candidates
linkedin jobs
can help you find the right person to
help you grow your business and your
first job post
is free so just visit linkedin.com slash
tim to learn more again that's
linkedin.com tim
to post your first job for free terms
and conditions
do apply
i have to ask because i'm sure i'm
wondering and i'm sure people listening
are wondering
i've heard stories of resistance and
conflict
when people parachute into different
places whether it's with an ngo
or with other organizations i have never
heard of
possible poisoning i mean that is a next
level
how do you explain that i mean would the
intent be to
make you sick to kill you i mean that's
i don't know how to make sense of that
degree of kind of counter-attack
again i think it's really dangerous to
assume
but i think that what i've learned
and what i used to you know and i used
to read novels about
the mystical and the magical that in
cultures including the united states
that were very orally based storytelling
myth making
can be as powerful and potent
as the real things and so
there was particularly in those years a
lot of gitty giddy you know people
believed
in wearing different amulets and
medicines
in a way you see the guys at silicon
valley kind of
replacing that with new things that we
do to give us a sense of strength
and so the way i always attributed it to
which is why
i would never accuse anyone have having
done it
but the threat of it and my own fear and
isolation
may have been made manifest in this
literal purging that i did
the threats were not that unusual
again i and i see it in places where
there's often insecurity and deeply oral
based
society and you've got to remember to
tim it was 30 years ago
and the world operated in very different
ways
then and i just was caught up in this
world that i had no understanding of
and of course is now a place that i'm
deeply in love with and
and love all of its different layers and
see the reflection
in our own societies we just make
manifest in different ways
at the time though you had just suffered
this
defeat of sorts it had really met with
tremendous opposition
what was your first meaningful win after
that
in your mind it could be small or big
for the first time when you're like okay
this this isn't a fool's errand like i'm
actually on to something i'm on the
right track here
that's such an interesting question i
had another crushing failure right after
where i analyzed a bank portfolio a
microfinance organization and saw that
i was excited by seeing all of the
problems in the portfolio and
and the ceo rather than sharing my
excitement that now we could actually
fix the problems
burned my work and didn't want to work
with me after that
and so i i had to learn a whole new
approach clearly i was in
that was in east africa that was in
kenya so i had a second big failure
the little winds were that in my
everyday life
the relationships that i was building
including with the person who served tea
with drivers were quite real
i kept going back to this human
potential that i was seeing
all around me and starting to understand
the crushingly
complex systems that were in their way
that nobody really wanted to confront
including
the supposed good guys the ngos the
nonprofits the leaders who were
also arbiters of who got resources and
who didn't and it actually reinforced
for me
why i believed in the power of business
of entrepreneurship
because i was in this other world where
who got control
of the resources meant everything
the first real win for me was when a
woman walked into my office in nairobi
and said that she was from rwanda which
was a country i was completely
unfamiliar with at the time
in fact i thought she said uganda and
they had
just 1986 they had just
passed a new law that abolished
napoleonic code under napoleonic code
women
were put in the same category as
children and the mentally
impaired and until that moment were
unable to open a bank account without
their husband's signature
and she asked me if i would go to the
country
to do a study if you will for
whether it might be possible to create
some kind of financial institution
specifically for women
it was the first time an african woman
had asked me to help solve a problem
i think i was so beat up by then and yet
really did feel the sense that if we
could get markets to work for poor women
they would have so much more dignity
than what i'd been seeing that i
probably
went for a three week assignment and
knew somewhere inside of me that i
wasn't leaving till we'd built
a bank so presumably that's what
that's what happened what happened so
that's what happened
i mean a couple things happened again i
had learned
from my own lack of humility that
it would have been really easy to go in
there and be like i i i i
but that if we were going to build an
enduring institution and i deeply
believe
in enduring institutions that
i had to be a minor role even if i was
doing a lot of the legwork
and so i was really lucky to find a
small group
of rwandan powerhouse women who are my
co-founders
and we did everything together
it reinforced the african adage that if
you want to go fast go alone if you want
to go
far go together and it became one of the
most extraordinary experiences of my
life because i
saw that you really could change a
little corner of history
with the right people the right kind of
capital the right value system
and certainly a lot of hard work i want
to
just put a bookmark in that for a second
and
ask from that initial plane flight
crying listening to joni mitchell
to that rwandan woman walking into your
office
how much time had elapsed roughly
roughly probably seven months
okay so over that seven month period
what were the ingredients that kept you
going
was it that you'd said to yourself come
hell or high water i'm sticking around
for a year had you made that kind of
commitment was it
i cannot go back to the u.s with my tail
between my legs and let all these
naysayers
prove themselves right was it something
else i'm just wondering what
kept you kind of slogging away
over that period of time i would say
that the whole first year and a half was
that slog
i would say a combination
of of this man tony trisiano
when he had given me this job offer and
he was like you're gonna go to
africa instead of do this and i was like
mr triciano don't you understand if i
don't go
i might never do it that moment kept
coming back to me and it's like how do i
go back to him
as a complete failure i have to like
show him
that we can do something but also tim
i saw the vibrancy i saw the
beauty and this world that i
had never imagined existed with people
who were so
eminently capable but who weren't really
given
a chance to be everything that they
could be and
it didn't seem like rocket science to me
to build different kinds of systems that
actually allowed their capability to
flourish
and so i think it was a mix of hubris
and a desire to be used in ways that i
felt that i
i had something to offer so coming back
to the bookmark
of rwanda and you finally start
to in close collaboration with these
co-founders these these local women
create something meaningful you start to
chalk up
some marks in the win category how do we
go from there
to acumen what is the timeline or
the series of events that leads and i
know we're covering earlier chapters but
i i like really looking at these things
closely because
it shows the development before you
reach escape velocity
and i think that's makes for at least
for me a fascinating study because
people get to see
sort of how you got to the point where
you could self
perpetuate and kind of build success on
success so rwanda to acumen
so rwanda to acumen saw
both the power of using markets with the
with the microfinance i learned
that it wasn't enough that giving women
just small
loans was amazing that you could give
them access to credit at say
12 a year rather than 400 percent a year
which is what they paid the money
lenders
that you could build community my
assumption that if you gave
women small bits of credit that it would
be enough for them to create jobs
was wrong most people aren't
entrepreneurs
and that's probably a really good thing
i could say it as an entrepreneur
married to an entrepreneur
we need we need the builders we need all
these other personalities around us
so i also started a little bakery with
20 women
to really understand what it would take
to build
entities that gave people good jobs and
that was a whole other
learning point in the apprenticeship if
you will before acumen
that access to markets is important
without the capabilities
of actually using those that
access we're only halfway there i think
because
i was beginning to understand that i
wanted to build
companies not just make small loans that
i wanted new skills
also in the context of east africa at
the time
degrees and other markers of success
particularly for women
seemed really important i was often
called shitano kidogo which means little
girl
even though we actually created a very
successful lending operation
so i applied to stanford business school
it was the only school i applied to
i thought well if i get in good if i
don't doesn't matter
why stanford besides the pretty trees on
palm drive
it was really really hard to get an
application anywhere
we only had word processors we didn't
have computers
it took 10 days to get a letter to
stanford or wherever and then another
10 days after they sent the application
to you
and then you had to write on that little
airplane paper
send it back it was a nightmare and that
particular year
harvard on its annual report
had a picture of all of the graduates
with dollar signs on the back of their
hats
and i thought well
i think i might be a misfit given that i
really want to
solve poverty that is so bad
that is so bad and i have like close
friends who have gone to harvard but oh
god that's terrible
but put yourself back there right 1987.
that was the height that was the mike
miller kid that was like the height of
market belief
in fact markets
exactly and so stanford had a public
management program that i thought
fit more with what i wanted to do with
my life it was very clear that i didn't
want to go back to
just make money i wanted to go back to
build the tools to build
companies that could employ and serve
poor people and so
at stanford i met an extraordinary
mentor named john gardner
and i think he shaped my life as well in
terms of getting me focused on the
united states as rest of the world
and talk to me about the importance of
leadership which i hadn't really thought
about as much tim then i went to the
rockefeller foundation
where i really saw the power of
philanthropy so by the time i was
nearing 40
i had worked in the private sector with
banking i had built
uh several institutions but most notably
duterte the microfinance organization
and this bakery and a couple of others
and then probably the other
critical thing that happened was the
rwandan genocide
so suddenly having worked on a social
justice institution by then that had
been in existence for seven years
and seeing a country explode into a
bloodbath
losing many of the people that i loved
and that i worked with
and seeing my co-founders play out every
role of the genocide from being
murdered to watching their families be
murdered to
being bystanders i think that was
probably
one of the most important not
experiences because god forbid i watched
it from afar
but both an understanding of patient
capital that the work of change is so
often
a couple steps forward and sometimes the
whole thing blows up
that societies are highly complex and
again
that at the the heart of my work
had to be a redefinition of what poverty
it was that
we so often look at poverty and we think
the answer is income
the answer is jobs what i had seen by
now
both in banking and in development and
certainly with the genocide
is that the opposite of poverty is
dignity it is
having a choice having opportunity
having agency over who you are in your
life
and what you're capable of doing and we
missed that
and that was really the beginning of
acumen
that we have all these tools we have the
superpower
in capitalism but when we raise it to
the rank of religion
and everything goes around one end
profit we can do amazing things but we
exclude
a huge chunk of the world and we create
great inequality we're seeing that today
not to mention not consider the
environment if
government decides everything or
top-down approaches to aid
it's just too easy to give to the people
that are
close to you or for reasons that have
nothing to do
with anything but power and so the
question i started asking myself is
what if we looked at capital as capital
understand it exists on a spectrum
take the power of business and capital
but rather than let it control us
control
it in service of creating a world where
we can actually solve our problems
acumen was born in 2001 with that idea
in mind
we're going a fair amount of time on
acumen no big surprise there
but i i want to spend just a few more
moments on the
rwandan genocide because i think
it may be helpful in exploring
the tendency that we all have to
oversimplify things and
the example that comes to mind and this
is based on
on reading and prepping for this
conversation that i'd love to hear you
speak to
is the tendency to separate the world
into monsters and angels
and how unhelpful that
can be and i think you you alluded to it
with your description of co-workers and
people you
knew or certainly people you had
exposure to being on all sides of this
genocide
victims bystanders perpetrators i'm sure
you had interacted on some level even
just going to the market or otherwise
with people who are on all sides of this
could you speak to that because i wrote
it down because it seemed
important not just within the context of
a genocide obviously but just in the
within the context of life in general
i'd love to hear any thoughts first
thought is
absolutely the i didn't just know people
in the market
our first executive director was jailed
as being one of the highest ranking
or the highest ranking planner at the
genocide before
the genocide she was co-creating a
liberal party based on
multi-tribal democracy with another one
of our co-founders
but when it was clear that power looked
like it was going to hutu power or the
genocide regime she switched and so
early on i
saw those who seek power
and those who seek purpose and that
power can be very tempting and i also
saw how in a time of real
insecurity and we're in one again it can
be very
easy for demagogic leaders at all levels
of society
to prey on insecurity and sometimes make
us do terrible things and that's where
monsters and angels came
in i was literally sitting
in a in a prison with
agnes the woman who was the major
perpetrator
need any asking her how this could have
happened
and there she was tim in a pink dress
of the prisoner's uniform her
head-shaped bald with a freckled face
you know she looked like a young woman
she didn't look like a monster and we
had
founded this institution
together we're taught that there are bad
people and good people monsters and
angels
and yet the truth of the matter is that
monsters and angels live in every single
one of us
monsters are our broken parts they are
our petty fears our insecurities the
grievances that that grow
and it's just too damn easy to
pull into those parts when we as a
society feel insecure
we blame other people we other them
and that was very much at the heart of
the genocide
and that that has very much
informed the way i see the world and the
way it acumen
even the way that we talk about and
inscribe our values
it's always intention it's always
recognizing
the light in the dark in almost any
choice that we make
so that we're much more cognizant that
there is no system
that's all good nor is there any human
being that is all good or all bad
i worry sometimes when i hear
conversations in the
social media moment that we are in that
it's capitalism's fault it's socialism's
fault
it's stakeholders it's shareholders
rather than can we focus on the values
here
what are we trying to solve and then can
we
pull back and find ways to use the best
of the tools
that we have at our disposal and
actually solve that problem everything
you just said i think is so
it's always been important i think it's
exceptionally important when you have
technologies that are in a sense
designed to polarized
because the incentives are such that
that becomes sort of a driving
design and engineering imperative in a
sense
and just to comment a bit further on
that
i would encourage everyone out there to
to look at the the work of darren brown
so darren brown is a
mentalist performer also an incredible
artist from
the uk and he has a number of specials
including one called the push he has
another i can't recall the name of
but the the objective
putting ethical considerations aside the
objective is to show how you can
mold people who are otherwise upstanding
moral people to do terrible things like
push someone off a building
or to shoot someone and the sad reality
is
that it is very much possible and that
it's easy to to sit on a moral high
horse
and levy judgment against others and to
say i would never have participated
in a rwandan genocide or i never would
have been
a member of the nazi party and so on and
so forth but
it's not quite that simple right and i
think to simplify it down
to the black and white people being all
one or all other is not in service of
solutions
i really appreciate you expanding on
that let's jump to acumen
acumen how do you choose the name or how
is the name
decided acumen stands for
perspective insight when we started
acumen i was focused on revolutionizing
philanthropy
and too often the way we think about
philanthropy is soft
this was saying again the hard and the
soft you've got to bring
an edge start with business start with
insight
build from there and bring the same
level of accountability that you would
expect from a financial investment into
the world
of social change therefore acumen so
could you just
recap for people i know we mentioned it
in the bio
but a lot has been discussed so far what
does acumen do acumen does three things
first we invest long-term patient
capital this is
10 to 15 year investment backed by
philanthropy
so equity and debt into entrepreneurs
that are going where markets have failed
healthcare education energy agriculture
we will invest not only for 10 to 15
years but
we accompany those entrepreneurs with
our social capital
our access to networks to supply chains
to knowledge sometimes to talent any
money that comes back gets reinvested
as you said tim to grow these companies
and scale
is at the heart of everything that we do
we then
need to tap into more traditional forms
of capital in the impact investing space
so we also have
a management company that runs several
for-profit
impact funds the second thing we do is
build a community of builders
through the world school for social
change acumen academy and that is not
only trying to identify
link inspire the talent that exists i
believe in every corner of the world
but also to offer rules tools blueprints
so that anyone anywhere who want to be
on the path of
social change using this combination of
head and heart hard skills and the what
i think are the even harder skills can
be part of it
the third is to measure what matters if
you're going to say that you
invest for impact you better be able to
measure
what that impact is a couple of years
ago
we spun off a company called
60 decibels that uses an approach to
measuring change
that we created called lean data which
we can talk about
it essentially upholds one of our our
main values which is listening
and it measures impact not from the
perspective
of the giver or the investor but from
the recipients from the customers
themselves so that we can actually serve
the poor in ways that we
hope to does the lean data
and uh i may ask some follow-up
questions just to ensure i'm clear on
how it works and how it works does that
apply
to the for-profit investing as well the
for-profit impact funds
yeah and in fact the reason we spun it
out is
a number of other nonprofit and
for-profit funds
asked us if we would essentially provide
them with lean data
consulting and we thought that again
going back to our mission we want to
change the way the world tackles poverty
we would serve that mission better if we
spun it out
let it grow and that 60 decibels which
has been really exciting to watch
take off i'd love to see blackrock using
it frankly all right blackrock
i'm sure there's somebody listening
comment again
let's just assume they are listening and
also for my benefit
for listeners could you just reiterate
what
lean data are if i'm going to be a
pompous princetonian
what exactly is or are lean data because
the
the question of measuring impact is one
that at least
in my circles comes up a lot like how do
you actually
do this how do you try to invest not
just for roi but for
good for impact but how do you do that
without just waving your hands around
and claiming that you've done a lot of
good i'd love to hear you expand on
on we invest in entrepreneurs that are
trying to build markets where they
haven't existed for people who make two
or three dollars a day
where there's no infrastructure there's
no trust there are very few skills
ed talent there's a lot of corruption
and complacency
and so it would be really easy for us to
essentially say that anything we do in a
difficult
environment is impact and so we decided
that we had to hold ourselves
accountable to a higher standard that at
the end of the day what really matters
when it comes to dignity is to
record and understand the voices of
those who are there to serve the poor
for many years tim our impact measuring
was fairly mediocre because we didn't
have the tools
once you had cell phone technology and
you could text
customers suddenly you had a
one-on-one communication where you
weren't in the room
where people aren't always as likely to
tell you the truth
because they don't really think you want
to hear it anyway but in this case the
more
anonymity they had the clearer people
would give so
imagine a solar light company we're the
largest off-grid
solar investor for the poor in the world
so we have a lot of them
we could go to a company like dlight and
text five six thousand customers
simultaneously
ask those customers a series of
questions
from which we can deduce what matters to
them
how many more hours of light do they
have when they buy a solar home system
that gives them
three lights a radio a television what
is the quality of that light
we can measure carbon offset that's easy
has their health changed because they're
no longer using
dangerous noxious kerosene are their
children doing better in education
which was an assumption we had when we
first went into it
then we collate all of that and suddenly
we can help our entrepreneurs understand
whether they're serving people
which is sometimes shocking when they
find that they actually are not in the
way that they thought they were
but equally we can start to look across
a sector
like solar electricity
and we can see which companies
may have the best product but it's
reaching people with the highest income
and so you've got to trade off which
companies are doing the most to displace
carbon but they may have another
trade-off and which companies have the
happiest customers
then we can decide more effectively
where we want to allocate our dollars
for
impact not only for financial returns it
not only has held us more accountable
tim
it's allowed the entrepreneurs a much
deeper understanding of who their
customers are
it allows us to see are we actually
reaching the poor which is our mandate
and it's shown us where we were wrong
when it came to
off-grid energy we assumed
as i said that kids would do better in
school they don't necessarily do better
in school if you want kids to do better
in school
in really really hot areas get them a
solar system
that includes a fan because with the fan
the era moves at night bugs are kept
away the kids sleep
they do better it's a lean approach
because you're not doing a three-year
randomized control trial and it is a
deep approach because you're hearing
from the perspective of those
who actually most matter yeah the
three-year randomized
approach has its place but honestly i
mean and this is speaking as someone who
is very involved with financing
scientific studies
it's not the right tool for all jobs and
particularly when you are
outside of a laboratory with lots of
uncontrolled variables it's just trying
to hammer screws
a lot of the time i think there's a real
place
for this lean data approach and i have a
question about
how this is used so here's a
hypothetical
maybe it's not hypothetical i would
imagine you've run into this if you
are acting as a non-profit and you're
investing in various enterprises
you can apply this data or offer this
type of tool
across the board i would imagine with
the
underlying belief that a rising tides
raises
all ships once you are a consultancy
and you are providing lean data to
for-profit companies
would you not say in a given sector run
into someone who wants you to avoid
conflicts by providing them this data
which could help their businesses
or business and they might say hey i
know that you have this valuable data
we would like to be the only one to
receive it in the x y and z category
otherwise it doesn't really give us a
competitive advantage so why would we
pay for it do you ever run into anything
like that much like a law firm would
have
a conflict check no i mean when there's
conflict then you know you're on to
something and i'm looking forward to
that day when we do
have that conflict i would say the more
internal
conversation that we have as a board is
how transparent to make it so that we
start actually taking seriously
the level of impact that different
investors around the world
actually are getting you mean
transparency in terms of like what you
learn how much to make publicly
available yeah and it goes to the ethos
at the beginning of acumen
even and i guess it goes to that girl we
were talking about
i just wanted to know the truth
ourselves so even if the world didn't
care we would always have a forced
ranking of our investments
and if you just sat there trying to
defend your investment
as an investor that was the way you
could get fired if you were the one
who talked about everything that was
wrong with it and what made you worried
that was the way you could become more
of a hero and now we're
we've grown quite large and i think we
have a different set
of questions that we ask but i think it
was that ethos
tim of holding ourselves to account for
the kind of impact that we are trying to
create in the world not protect
that allowed acumen to partner with just
incredible
market makers like the guys who founded
dlight which has brought
clean solar light and electricity to
over 100 million people
and really launched an energy revolution
and taught me that the kind of investing
we need to think about right now
at scale doesn't only reward the
building of a single company
but those companies who ultimately
create entire markets
i think that's the next frontier in so
many ways so you gave
you know an example just one example of
many of
just the scale the large-scale impact
that acumen and these these various
spin-offs and for-profit funds have been
able to have
in the world but if we go back to 2001
circa 2001 acumen
you know i always like to to ask aside
from acumen did you have any other names
that were on the short list for
consideration that you remember do you
remember any other rough treatment
i do of course i do in fact we had a you
know 2001 just to put us back again
it was the dot-com craziness well 2000
2001 by by the time i picked document
and we started there was a bust
but um you could not get a url
and no names were working and so i had
this night at the
rockefeller foundation where i was
working in and we came up with
really really great names including
ain't your grandma's philanthropy
that's great i think that was my brother
mike's but i'm not i can't remember but
there was a lot of why involved in the
the naming of acumen and then
i really love the word immersion i still
do it's one of the principles of moral
imagination
there's a great line from tilly olsen
where she says may you live
a life of immersion i'm paraphrasing but
what price will you pay
to truly understand the complexity of
the
issues that we are trying to solve you
have to get close
ryan stevenson the civil rights activist
says you have to get proximate
i say you have to immerse it's the same
but when we did
trials particularly across gender women
were attracted to the word immersion men
hated it
hated it and so acumen seemed a little
less
offensive to one of the other two groups
how did you test it were you
sending out a poll to a group of friends
how did you do the split testing well a
friend of mine antonio bowring was
working for a
now no longer.com called i think it was
called march 1st
they did this big ideation project with
us so they
actually did some true consumer testing
but i also having so many people in my
life and being an
extrovert just kept asking asking asking
and
i couldn't find a single man who was
with me on immersion
and in fact i can remember one person
was like i just hear that word jaclyn i
feel like you're making me drown
in a c
there is something to that there are
moments where you feel like you're
drowning
but then you come out to clarity but so
we decided
i never would have guessed in a million
years that you would have such a gender
split on immersion maybe i'm just a
language geek so i find it
attractive as a concept i think now in
fact
our housing company in pakistan javad
aslam
he actually named one of his funds the
immersion fund
once you really think about it's a
beautiful word
all of us right now need to immerse more
in each other's lives
all of us need to design with the
imagination
not just through our own lens but with
the imagination that is morally based
you don't get that if we don't have
immersion i think it's changed
yeah i was just going to ask if you
could just explore for a moment and then
we're going to come back to acumen and
i'm going to ask you about the earliest
wins and if you could speak to those but
i don't want to gloss over
moral imagination could you
just take a moment i think you're kind
of walking into that territory but
just to frame it what is moral
imagination
moral imagination is essentially putting
yourself
in another shoes and building from their
perspective as i said it's
we often design through the lens just of
our own imagination
that doesn't work when we're designing
for people whose lives are completely
unlike our own
so moral imagination starts with empathy
but i've learned time and time again
that empathy by itself
reinforces the status quo or at least
risks doing so
and so the idea of moral imagination is
understanding by immersing
a particular problem and then thinking
systemically
about those issues that get in people's
way and then frankly being honest enough
to recognize where people get in their
own way
and then moving from there
when you say empathy in some cases
enforces the status quo
could you elaborate on that this do you
mean that it's just in
us verses not verses but like an us and
them kind of the the savior of the fill
in the blank is it that
dichotomy that's created or not that
that is what empathy does
of course but what do you mean by
enforcing the status quo
i think it's even deeper i mean i think
when i first learned about the moral
imagination was in college
when i was at charlottesville ironically
given everything that happened in
charlottesville a few years ago
and i signed up to
bring a turkey dinner and all the
trappings of a christmas
to this community that was 30 minutes
away
from the university where low-income
people lived
i was also kind of a wild coed and so we
had this big party
we asked everyone to bring food and
toys to make a perfect christmas for
these kids
i was really excited because i felt at
some level
so sorry for these people that didn't
get to have a christmas
the next morning my girlfriend and i got
up and
we got in her car we loaded it with all
the stuff we were both completely
hungover
we drove into this place
that i'd never been to a place like that
before and it was literally when we got
to the house
it's like a shanty a shack and suddenly
i just felt shame
tim i was like oh my god like
i don't know who these kids are i don't
know what kind of things they like i
don't know if the parents
want the kids to know that somebody else
is bringing them christmas
and this is all wrong
and literally i said to suzanne my
friend i was like just keep the car
running
and grab the stuff i ran it i threw it
on the porch i ran back to the car
it was like just go and i think in a way
it was the beginning of my moral
imagination that
that act was an act of empathy it was
well intended
and i hope that they had a really lovely
christmas
but the moral imagination would have
said look am i willing to do the work of
actually
understanding who these people are at
the very least
and building from there if i'm not
find an organization that does even
better
ask the questions around what got them
there in the first place
and where can i be spending my time and
my energy and my capital
to solve that problem and i'm not saying
we shouldn't give
charity i think there's a real role
for moving from that place of empathy
and
from that place of unbridled love in a
moment
our job right now when when the pandemic
and
everything that's happened in the world
has broken our systems open
is to think bigger than that and to hold
ourselves to account
at a systemic level and that's that's
what my obsession is
thank you for explaining that and uh
telling that story also which i think
drives it home
acumen so winging a prayer
good idea you've tested the name
here we go buckle up do you recall
any of the first wins where you're like
okay i think this might actually do
something
oh yeah i mean i would call it like it
was yesterday
we had helped put together this
collaboration this deal
to bring long-lasting malaria
bed nets into tanzania it started with
sumitomo who had developed this
bed net and also recognized that 95
of malaria is in africa and yet there
was no manufacturing capability
for this particular kind of bed net and
so it was a real experiment could we
build
manufacturing capability with with
similar throughput rates to the kind
that you might get in
asia where the long-lasting bed nets
were created
we went through all these different
entrepreneurs we identified this
incredible guy named anusha in arusha
tanzania
and worked with global fund to buy these
nets and
didn't really know what was going to
look like and of course i'd seen a lot
of things fail
this was a complex collaboration and
then i went to go visit
just as the factory was getting going
and there was one line
of bed net making machines and i was
like
this is cool i love operations factory
operations
a few months later i went back and there
were four
a few months later i went back and there
were eight and there was that
moment when suddenly i was seeing
hundreds of women
operating these machines that i thought
oh my goodness we're doing this
and then they ended up creating jobs for
10 000 people
manufacturing 30 million nets a year
they ended up being 15
of global production and when you think
about that that's like a half a billion
people
who have gotten access to malaria bed
nets because of this
little company and not so little anymore
company in arusha tanzania i was like
bingo
this is what we're about boom proof of
concept
boom let's look at this example
because i'd like to explore the thought
process or the process
a bit in so much as i think
many people who are considering
impact investing or even perhaps
starting
a firm or a fund or a company that has
that
as its intended purpose particularly a
fund
they might solicit
proposals or business proposals and then
choose from that menu of options but it
seems like you started with
selecting a problem and then you
canvassed to find
candidates is that how you approached it
in the beginning we selected
sectors we were mostly focused at the
very beginning on health technologies
and then the idea was we would find
entrepreneurs i was and am such a
believer
in entrepreneurs and in fact people
would say oh
are you trying to solve malaria and i'd
be like no
we are trying to find those health
technologies that could fundamentally
change people's lives and bring them
dignity
now again we're in a very different
place where
we have all local teams on the ground
depending on the region
there's much more focus on the sectors
and tim what we find then is if you
think about acumen as a laboratory
when we see a company really move up
like a d light then we can start to
build
other companies around it to really help
create that ecosystem
so we're a bit different in the us for
instance
it wouldn't make sense for us to be
looking at off-grid energy or investing
in the social determinants of healthcare
financial inclusion and workforce
development which we feel are so
critical to
where the nation is now when it comes to
the poor or low-income people
the uh you know you mentioned sumitomo
which is japanese and uh developing an
ecosystem around a company
is is in some ways very japanese concept
or it's something that's been very well
explored and developed indicated to
these
i suppose conglomerates would be a lazy
way to to translate that
in japan but that as is a very long-term
approach
yeah absolutely i mean that's so look at
some of these companies they've lasted
us
a very long time they're not five or ten
year companies
i look at your story i look at
your chronology and
one thing that stands out to me and
please feel free to disabuse me of any
misconceptions but
you cut your teeth in banking
you got to understand that machine from
the inside
you then well simultaneously
in some respects and then after looked
at microfinance access to capital
you started a bakery i don't think
that's a small thing you you actually
were boots on the ground
getting first-hand experience in an
immersive way
of what entrepreneurship looked like in
your chosen environment
you got your ass kicked in west africa
but put another way you really got an
extended education
on someone else's charter with someone
else's
organization and support you through
that entire
period of time are developing grit
learning what doesn't work
certain approaches to parachuting in
you're learning conversely what does
work
and then suddenly you're jaclyn
novogratz
founder and ceo of acumen but i think
it's tempting for people to jump
straight to the acumen
and i'd love to
hear you answer the question what advice
you would give to young people who say
they want to change the world because it
strikes me
that if you had tried to jump straight
to acumen correct me if i'm wrong but
you wouldn't have been viewed as
backable you wouldn't have had the
operational experience
it just wouldn't have worked i sometimes
worry that these
young or older people quite frankly who
could really
make a positive dent in the world are
putting the cart before the horse
in terms of skill development they don't
have the chops but they want to change
the world
you've spoken to students i know you've
given commencement speeches but
for those people listening or like i
just want to change the world what
advice would you
give to them well the first would be
this idea of just follow your passion
i don't even really even understand what
that means
even though my whole life i have been
very clear
about the the way i wanted to create
change and for whom
it wasn't this as you said
out of the box really understanding that
we were going to use different
forms of capital and support it with the
right kind of talent to
work a system to create real change i
would say
just start don't start by asking
you know what is my purpose what is my
passion start by asking
what are the problems that need to be
solved
which ones attract me and take a step
toward that
take one step and the work will teach
you where you need to take the next step
build tools in your toolbox if you still
don't know what your passion or your
purpose is as you take those steps
follow a leader and learn from that
leader there is something so powerful
and i think this is
what you're getting at to tim in
apprenticing
i would say i apprenticed for 15 years
and also to your point that bakery
in some ways probably looked like a girl
scout project to a lot of people
when i think about some of the most
important things i've ever done in my
life
that one sits at the top for all the
reasons that you
implied i had to learn the gritty
realities
talk about learning humility i also saw
that we could succeed
and i had to let go of a lot of my
assumptions yet again
and so i do think you're right skipping
steps
particularly because life is both
shorter than we think it is and it's
longer than we
think it is it doesn't serve the world
and it doesn't serve you
here here you've also i don't know if
you've said this or written it
but i vaguely remember and maybe you can
provide some
some context here for when it was said
or written but
something along the lines of if you try
to keep all of your options
open you may just end up with a bunch of
options
i actually think jim collins said that
to me when i was like
to be his student and i have paraphrased
jim um i say that a lot where it's like
well
you know jacqueline i need to keep my
options up and i'm like seriously
just commit to something this
we don't tell young people or even old
people
we don't expect that enough
but i think the cultiva of the
individual is the is also the cult of
optionality
and the secret is that when you commit
to something particularly something
bigger than yourself
it will set you free and suddenly you
will find
a freedom and layering of life that you
never really understood you had
that is something that i don't think i
would have fully been able to wrap my
head around
until just in the last few years
really becoming dedicated to scientific
research around psychedelic compounds
and uh i don't want to take us down that
rabbit hole necessarily
certainly your brother mike has a fair
amount
i'm the wrong sibling for that one yeah
yeah my brother mike has a format to say
about that
mr mister this ain't your grandma's
philanthropy
or whatever but the great relief
and unburdening of
me centric living that comes from
dedicating yourself to something larger
is is really profound and i mean it's
not entirely
altruistic it's like it's so relieving
uh i just it's hard to overstate that
and i'm glad you mentioned it well and
none of this is entirely altruistic
if we're seeking purpose if we all buy
into
you know throws that so many men live
lives of quiet desperation and we don't
want to be those people
then there is no clearer path than
making a commitment to problems that
might be so big you won't solve them in
your lifetime
because then you are constantly just
starting you are constantly
learning and unlearning and renewing and
i think that's been
also the story of this work of
trying to solve these big problems with
entrepreneurs that are
as relentless in their seeking it's just
that
what drives them is to solve a problem
what does not drive them is
is just profit though they recognize
they need the profit for long-term
financial sustainability and scale
it's the prioritization you mentioned
following a leader earlier
and also apprenticing and
there are many different types of
leaders out there many
people who might seem to be good mentors
but make terrible mentors
could you speak to an example in your
life
of a mentor or a leader it doesn't have
to be john gardner i wrote that down
just because you mentioned it and
mentioned john in passing from i believe
that was your gsb days right the
the stanford days to what makes a good
mentor
or a good leader the type
you might want to follow or learn from
for me there's really no one like john
gardner in my life tim
he was this very patrician man who
almost spoke in cohen's by the time i
met him we were 50 years apart
an age so he gave a lot of wisdom
where he stood apart and again we need
him so much right now
he was the only republican on lyndon
johnson's
democratic cabinet and was the head of
health education and welfare so he was
at the table and negotiating some of the
great civil rights legislation
talk about courage he would say things
to me
like you know focus on being interested
jacqueline
not interesting when i would get some
fancy job offer
and he would think that it's that was a
vanity project rather than a character
building project
john left the cabinet and resigned his
his position in protest of the vietnam
war
and in response he created a grassroots
citizens organization at age 54 called
common costs and it was that level of
integrity and of doing the right thing
not the easy thing
that i think we're all yearning for in
our leaders today
john could have done anything but when i
think about what legacy is
i think about him and i look at the
the now you know we've had over a
million sign ups on our
on acumen academy when i see these
hundreds and hundreds of acumen fellows
and the entrepreneurs i sometimes hear
john's
words in them and i think
this man who's been dead for almost 20
years is fully alive
with the kind of legacy that matters
because he focused on investing
in the world around him and not just in
himself
so jacqueline i have good news bad news
depending it's
actually the same news i just don't know
how you're going to take it which is i
think we're going to have to do
or i would like to do round two at some
point because we're there's no way we're
going to cover even a fraction of what i
have in front of me
but but we can do a do-over
yeah oh definitely not a duo are you
kidding me
you've been you've been you've been
nothing but net for an hour and 40
minutes i'm not letting this one go
i would like to ask about actually
first a short question then a longer
question the shorter question is going
to be about books
and the longer questions going to be
about advice
to different types of listeners those
people who have more time than money
maybe they're early in their careers
maybe they're just in a transition
then you have the investor types i would
consider myself an investor type also
who are looking to have more impact make
more impact and then to institutional
those people who might be in positions
within institutions
before we get to that so you were you
were kind enough to
contribute to tribe of mentors
my last book thank you very much for
that and you answered
quite a number of questions one of those
questions
is what is the book or books you've
given the most as a gift and why
or what are one to three books that have
greatly influenced your life
now you mentioned a few now you can also
revise these
one was invisible man by ralph ellison
another things fall apart
bye can you pronounce this author's name
for me chinuachebe
thank you there's so many words and
names that i know how to read
i recognize but i have no idea how to
pronounce and then a fine balance
by here's another one right mystery
wrote in mystery
there we go if you had to pick one of
these
or another book it doesn't have to be
one of these three but
a book that you've given as a gift or
that has had
a strong impact on you for people to
start with
which might you recommend and why of
course i recommend people also
read your books the blue sweater and
also manifesto for moral revolution so
not to exclude those but for the sake of
conversation now
if they weren't those books what comes
to mind i have reasons for each of those
books and certainly the invisible man in
this moment of the black lives matter's
protests and the continuing racial
reckoning
invisible men really taught me to not
see through
anybody ever but the book i give right
now
in this time of so much despair is
victor frankel's man search for meaning
where he really looks at people in the
holocaust
and asks himself why did some just sort
of crumple up and die and others stayed
resilient and strong
and that at the end of the day no one
can take our dignity away from us
and so i think that we have to be
reminded right now that
between stimulus and response
there is a choice and we're in that
moment and
and i have seen myself personally so
often
that in the darkest times we can find
our best selves
and that's our opportunity right now and
so i think for this moment tim
man search for meaning is should be
required reading for all of us
i could not endorse that
strongly enough for anyone who's
listening to this also
across 500 plus episodes of this podcast
the single book that has come up most
often is man's search for meaning so if
you have not read this book
do yourself a favor do everyone around
you a favor
and uh pick it up it is just a
tremendous
tremendous book and also a great example
of
someone in this case victor frankl
embracing something larger than himself
the completion of
man's search for meaning the concept of
writing this and compiling it as a book
that helped him to get through so much
suffering also
yeah and moral imagination that he had
in seeing
not just the ugliness of the world that
is and the humility that that takes but
he truly had the audacity to imagine
what could be
and to see the infinite potential in
every human being
let's use that as a segue to help others
to embrace the audacity to imagine what
they might do
you can take these in any order and
there might be other archetypes we
we want to touch upon but for those
people listening and i'll just grab
three we have the the person with
right now for any number of reasons more
time than financial resources what they
might do
and you don't have to tackle them in
this order the individual investor
so that's someone who is accustomed to
perhaps investing in public equities or
in my case and many others startups
cryptocurrency whatever it might be who
would like to begin
to experiment with investing
for greater social impact or impact
and then the players in the
institutional
space those people who may be at asset
management firms or
or otherwise what who also
would like to either in a man in a
management or leadership position begin
to steer the ship
at least carving off a portion of
activities
to focus on impact maybe lean data
or who just as entrepreneurs within
these companies want to
want to try something what would you say
to any of those groups
to the person with not a lot of money
but time
i would say focus on both immersion
and understanding the problems around us
and also another
practice from the book which is
accompaniment by accompaniment
what i mean to walk with someone to try
and understand their problem not take it
on and solve it for them but to help
them build the muscle so that they can
solve it themselves
by book in this case you mean manifest
manifesto for moral revolution
and the whole idea of moral revolution
is you know give more to the world than
you take it's not
there are some who have the moral
responsibility and some who do not it's
like
all of us so i really appreciate that
you would ask for all three categories
when you look at the brokenness of our
criminal justice system
at the opioid epidemic poverty
the arts community that's out of work
there is such an
opportunity to be of use
to pay visits to just talk to people who
are lonely right now
to be more conscious about the way that
we spend our money even for small things
and buy sustainably and so it's building
into
your everyday a much greater
consciousness and awareness of
the fact that our action and our
inaction impacts people
everywhere for the individual investor
i would say that one of the broken
parts of our current system of
capitalism which bifurcates
how we make money and how we give it
away
is that we often disregard how people
are treated
inside and outside our companies and
then we
as well as the environment and then we
try to make amends for the fact that we
are the status quo with our philanthropy
on the outside
and that model is deeply broken
as investors how do we think more
holistically about the impact
that we're we're making positive and
negative
with all parts of our money across that
spectrum
there has never been such opportunity as
there is right now
to invest in extraordinary entrepreneurs
that are
that are reimagining how to use the
tools of capitalism to solve
big problems as i said to him they exist
in every of
every country and we have to think with
more
openness to how we would look at our
overall portfolio
again thinking of it going from
philanthropy to
more market driven returns we have a
company in the united states called
every table
and it is a fast food healthy nutritious
affordable restaurant chain now in los
angeles
it's about eight different restaurants
and with the pandemic it just has
exploded in the best ways of delivering
food
and partnering with governments and
individual philanthropists
that are willing to pay meals forward so
that
people in low-income parts of los
angeles can
get healthy affordable food with black
lives matter protests
what sam polk the entrepreneur
understood is that
he had within him within his operation
individual employees who had the
capability to become franchisees
but in the united states the franchise
model usually
expects that you will have your own
capital to put into the system from the
beginning
so he's created a university and he's
now
raised probably three of 13 million
dollars you know seven year debt at two
percent
that will allow him to identify the
entrepreneurs amongst his employees
give them the opportunity to start their
own franchise enable them to have forty
thousand dollar a year salaries for the
next three years
and hopefully we're going to see a whole
group of
black and latinx entrepreneurs that are
running every table franchises
in of and for their communities
that's the kind of creativity that
exists right now in the united states
and
everywhere else in the world that we
work from pakistan to colombia
if i were and i am an investor
that really cares about impact i would
urge myself and urge everyone else to
think more expansively
about themselves as investors using all
the tools at our disposal and for the
big institutions
i would say one thing that as long as we
have an investment model
that is still based on extraction
rather than actually investing for
good we are going to continue to build
more and more
inequality in ways that are fully
unsustainable for this world
it has been really exciting to me to see
not only a 700 billion dollar impact
investing sector
emerge over the last 20 years but also
to see
big companies like blackrock and others
say enough
but we've got to move from a place where
we do no harm
to one where real investing is not
only accounted for by what a few
shareholders
earn come what may but that real
investing is
truly measured by the amount of the jobs
the beauty the human capability
the opportunities that are enabled in
the world
so i would love to ask you for
some simple next steps for
also each of those three categories like
what people could do tomorrow
and the reason i ask that is that i
think it's very easy for
people to take next steps towards impact
investing whether the
form of investment is time or
money or energy and to push it into the
someday category i think it's very easy
to do and
and i don't wrong them i don't wrong
anyone for that because
it can seem like kind of stumbling
through a fog
if they don't have a direction in so
much as if we take just an individual
investor
i'll use myself as an example you know
it took me
a long time to build the relationships
and the deal flow
in the for-profit sector where the pass
fail marks are very clearly defined
to get to the point where i could invest
in really good companies and for people
who have developed those relationships
and put in the time
to get an understanding of let's just
call it the
the the more black and white capitalist
model
uh it can be very intimidating the idea
of starting from scratch to try to
figure out what makes a good
impact investment could you speak to
that for the person who has
uh you would tackle the investment side
first but the kind of individual the
institutional and then a person with
more time like what could they do
tomorrow or next week for instance is
is a simple answer like hey if you want
to figure this out
invest in one of our for-profit impact
funds understanding that this podcast is
not giving investment advice i'm not a
registered investment advisor blah blah
blah blah blah
but i would love to hear what some
simple next steps
might be if they agree with you they
want to
begin to get a get some skin in the game
to get on the playing field i mean i
appreciate the self-promotional
invitation there
tim if i'm going to go down that path
i would say that the simplest
next step would be to get onto acumen
academy
on our website and check out the courses
including the path of moral leadership
that seth godin who's so
extraordinary in every way has helped us
build
which takes the different practices of
the book and really looks at the
examples
of companies that go from chocolate and
coffee in colombia to
bed nets to chickens in ethiopia and
really
shows some of the fundamental business
models
that have enabled extraordinary levels
of change
as well as identified role models so i
would get on to the acumen academy
the second would be both for
institutional and individual there are
increasingly trade associations for lack
of a better word
that can direct you to really strong
impact investors
the aspen network of development
entrepreneurs is probably
the best andy and de.org i think
and so get smart learn on the acumen
website are also
all of our companies and the stories of
many of them
that give a real sense again not only of
the possible but of ways that that
people can get involved
as i said tim all of our actions
increasingly
matter and so paying more attention to
where and how we buy and giving
ourselves license
within our communities to be a little
radical
in the way that we might make sure that
we're investing
in each other and giving back more than
we take
i think becomes a mantra every day
having a
my brother michael at galaxy and going
such different routes as young people
and yet all along the way asking these
questions of how do you change the world
how do you change the world how do you
change the world
i actually think it's about getting
started where you can with what you have
and who you are but it's also about
asking yourself
the question not am i making more money
am i richer famous
more famous more beautiful today but
rather
what am i doing in the way that i run my
business
and the way that i invest my dollars in
the way that i
interact with everyone from the waiter
to
the president of some fancy bank
what am i doing to insist on
elevate and enable human dignity i would
start there
and then i'd get smart you invoked
the name of a mutual friend who texted
me
prior to this conversation also seth
godin
and i bring him back up because
i think seth would agree that
it's easy to hide with
big aspirations in the sense that if you
say well i just want to change the world
it's easy to hide you can make the
argument that you're not ready you can
make the argument that you have to make
a little bit more money you can
use all sorts of socially acceptable
excuses not to take action
and that there are in fact
easy things simple things and you can do
the easy thing first
if in doubt don't hit snooze for three
years
go to acumen.org just commit to spending
60 minutes
educating yourself you will learn
something or getting manifesto for a
moral revolution
your book commit to getting that on
kindle maybe you try it for just 20
pages
do you give it a taste test see what you
think there are
simple things that you can do first and
it's easy to hide behind the big
ambitious world-changing thing that may
or may not come
that's a way of hitting snooze and i
think absolving oneself of
responsibility
and i'm as guilty of that as the next
person so i'm not casting stones
but there are some very simple options
here as you mentioned
including just going to acumen.org or
acumen.org forward slash
moral revolution dig around commit to 30
60 minutes there's very limited downside
and i want to ask you maybe two more
questions
and one i didn't want to ask you earlier
because i didn't want to make you
self-conscious
but you are really good
exceptional at nailing the goldilocks
amount
of using people's names in this case
tim like you use it very well you don't
over
use someone's name it's a very
effective way of i would hope that i'm
already engaged but keeping me even more
engaged is that something that you've
always done or is that something that
you developed
somehow tim you're making me laugh
you're reminding me of the first book
thing i did with blue sweater and i got
off the stage and a famous actor came up
to me and said
oh my god you do real so well
and i was like excuse me
not to imply that this is some
artificial thing i
i i feel like it it's of course genuine
but it's something that not a lot of
people do
or they try to play real so
deliberately they end up saying your
name every other sentence and you're
like i feel like you're trying to sell
me a
used car or something but you are no
very natural i think it goes
i actually think it goes to immersion
which is probably why i didn't get to
like talk about
many of the things i really wanted to
talk about because i just get so
focused on what who you are what you're
talking about that
no it's not conscious it's not conscious
so
i wish i had a better answer oh what a
gift
i quite appreciated it well let's let's
give i'm going to cheat i'm going to ask
you more than two questions but
my last question is going to be
recommendations closing comments things
you'd like to say
before we wrap up for this round one
but would you like to give a teaser for
other things that you would have liked
to have talked about that we didn't get
around to
is there anything you'd like to mention
lest it be left out of this
this first edition i really appreciate
that you are even asking me that
opportunity giving me that opportunity
and i think another reason that i
probably know when to say your name or
not or don't even know but
without meaning to flatter you truly are
deeply engaging
conversationalist an interviewer and i i
really appreciate that
yeah you really are there are many
things
that i'd like to talk about in terms of
what it actually means
to bet on character that i think that
one of the mistakes i
made at the beginning of acumen was to
be so excited by a particular technology
or business idea and over time
understanding character and that you
used in a lot of the words
the grit the resiliency the vision the
ability to take feedback
a whole other conversation i'd love to
have with you
is on courage i i shared with you at the
beginning of this
that you do remind me of my brothers
plural
and that you've got just an
extraordinary
level of what looks like fearlessness
and i'm betting that
you've learned to flex those
fearlessness muscles early in your life
and you practice them all
along but because of the the
vulnerability and the real courage that
you've shown
in your podcast with debbie millman
there was a whole set of muscles that
went untended
and that the key to us becoming not just
good at what we do or famous or what
have you but becoming wise
is to learn how to flex those
muscles of courage that we don't always
flex
and i think this is another moment in
history that really demands that of us
and third i'd love to go deeper into the
holding of tensions
that we are at a moment in history where
we have to learn
how to find each other across what
might seem like impossible divides to
cross
and yet we're all we have each other
and we're on this earth for a short time
and it's up to us to be a generation
that actually gets stuff done rather
than being seen as being
blind and disconnected from one another
and so
acumen has worked for 20 years in
communities where people are raised to
hate each other and when i think about
who
our global community is it also has been
raised
with many many different people who were
taught to hate each other
and yet it is possible to build
out of diversity a sense of wholeness
but not
not if we just focus on what we're
getting
from an organization or a nation or
community
but the responsibility that we have for
each other and i hear that
in different conversations that you've
been having with people
and i'd love to go there too finally i
would just love to say
you're really one of a kind tim ferriss
and the prep
and the curiosity that you bring
and frankly the love that you bring to
every conversation and to the work that
you're doing is really unparalleled
when i think of true moral imagination
it's based in
a deep curiosity and and people who are
willing to
follow that thread of curiosity to
wherever it might lead
and so thank you for modeling that for
all of us thank you so much
talking about unflexed muscles i'm not
very uh i haven't flexed the muscle of
letting things land very much
so i'm gonna i'm gonna tuck that away
and think about it for the rest of today
so thank you very much
for saying that and for providing
such a wonderful conversation to me and
to everyone
listening my god you are so good you're
so good at this
and you're such an inspiration
and i i just love the fact
that you have traveled so many paths
that many would assume diverge and yet
you have found a way to make them
converge
if that makes sense you have the
operational
chops you have
the toughness and the honesty to speak
truth and i recall the process of doing
homework for this finding
someone i can't recall who it was saying
something along the lines maybe an
investor
in one of your funds i don't know saying
something along the lines of jacqueline
you always talk about love but then
we get you around the negotiating table
and you're so hardcore
and you are living proof that those do
not need to
be mutually exclusive furthermore that
they can be mutually reinforcing
you can combine the hard and the soft in
a way that is tremendously effective in
the world
and that in fact there are some might
say an imperative
or there are imperatives to be able to
combine those things
and to not view them as separate and
i'm just so extremely happy that
i had the chance to have this
conversation and i hope it is just
the first of many so thank you again for
taking the time
thank you tim and i i'm just so honored
truly i feel
so so privileged and thank you too for
making manifest the heart and the soft
it's what we need to do in our world
together and so looking forward to many
conversations as well
and uh and i wish you good luck on this
to be
continued i love saying that i always
mean it
and i i mean it very very sincerely
right now everyone
check out acumen.org there's a lot there
that is worth digging into we will have
show notes
for everything we've discussed links
galore
resources galore at tim.blog forward
slash podcast
that will be easy to find and until next
time
ask dumb questions they're often the
smartest
questions you could ask be honest bet on
character
use courage it is the mother attribute
for all other attributes i'm stealing
someone else's quote but
all other attributes at their testing
point require courage
and thanks for tuning in
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up in
the uh the world of the esoteric as i do
it could include favorite articles that
i've read
and that i've shared with my close
friends for instance
and it's very short it's just a little
tiny bite
of goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by magic spoon
magic spoon is a brand new cereal that i
eat just about every day that is
low carb high protein and zero sugar i
just ate a huge bowl of their cocoa
flavor
about an hour ago after a short workout
magic spoon cereal
has received a lot of attention since
launching last year
time magazine included it in their list
of best inventions of 2019
and forbes called it the future of
cereal it tastes just like your favorite
sugary cereal from childhood remember
that
but it's actually good for you each
serving has 11 grams of protein
3 grams of net carbs 0 grams of sugar
and
only 110 calories it's also gluten free
grain free keto friendly soy free and
gmo free all the things it's delicious
and i don't say that lightly because
most of this healthy
version of x stuff is not delicious but
these guys really nail it magic spoon
has nailed it it comes in your favorite
traditional
cereal flavors like cocoa frosted and
blueberry you can try them all by
grabbing a variety pack
at magicspoon.comtim or you can just
grab a box
for a bunch of boxes i'm going to order
some more today of
the cocoa which is my personal favorite
but there is a new
contender for favorite flavor because
they just
launched two limited edition flavors
honey nut and peanut butter which are
delicious i am a sucker for peanut
butter
and it is outstanding so i think coco
and peanut butter are my two
new favorite flavors and fun fact my
friends are
also obsessed with magic spoon one of
the podcasts
most popular guest dr peter tia
routinely crushes six to seven servings
at a time that's a lot
with no glycemic response he's looked at
this with a glucometer
he likes it so much he invested other
friends two very fine gentlemen and also
past podcast guests
kevin rosen ryan holiday also invested
so
go to magicspoon.com tim to grab some
delicious cereal
and try it for yourself today use promo
code tim that's tim
at checkout to save five dollars off of
your order and magic spoon is so
confident in their product
i have boxes and boxes and boxes it's
backed with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money
no questions asked get your next
delicious bowl
of guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
tim and use the code tim to get five
dollars off
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep my god am i in love with eight
sleep
good sleep is the ultimate game changer
more than 30
of americans struggle with sleep and i'm
a member of that sad group temperature
is one of the main causes of poor sleep
and heat has always been my nemesis
i've suffered for decades tossing and
turning throwing blankets off putting
them back
on and repeating ad nauseam but now i am
falling asleep in record time
faster than ever why because i'm using a
simple device
called the pod pro cover by eight sleep
it's the easiest
and fastest way to sleep at the perfect
temperature it pairs dynamic cooling and
heating with biometric tracking to offer
the most advanced
but most user-friendly solution on the
market
i polled all of you guys on social media
about the best
tools for sleep enhancing sleep
and eight sleep was by far and away the
crowd favorite i mean people were just
raving fans of this
so i used it and here we are add the pod
pro cover to your current mattress and
start sleeping
as cool as 55 degrees fahrenheit or as
hot as 110 degrees fahrenheit
it also splits your bed in half so your
partner can choose a totally different
temperature
my girlfriend runs hot all the time she
doesn't need
cooling she loves the heat and we can
have our own bespoke temperatures
on either side which is exactly what
we're doing now for me
and for many people the result eight
sleep users fall asleep up to 32 percent
faster
reduce sleep interruptions by up to 40
and get more restful sleep
overall i can personally attest to this
because i track it in all sorts of ways
it's the total solution for enhanced
recovery so you can take on the next day
feeling
refreshed and now my dear listeners
that's you guys you can get 250
off of the pod pro cover that's a lot
simply go
dot to slash tim or use code tim that's
eight all spelled out e-i-g-h-t sleep
dot com
slash tim or use coupon code tim
t-i-m eight sleep dot com slash tim
for 200 off your pod pro cover